one member of miracles Christian
Democrats who initially backed quotas
for women but voted against the motion
was labor minister Ursula von der Leyen
her main opponent Family Affairs
Minister Christina Schroeder also a
conservative favors a voluntary system
as does the Chancellor but the
Chancellor's party has been forced to
compromise they've now agreed to include
in their election manifesto a 30-percent
quarter for women from 2020 via last
piece we will give businesses until 2020
to change and then we'll get serious
boos from the opposition but the
family's minister insisted her voluntary
quotas scheme was working outside spite
of concrete requirements from companies
were not introduced until 2011 memories
I think and I was the one who introduced
them and this method has worked the
conflict presents a challenge for the
government in this election year and the
opposition is pulling no punches reality
will not change because you write
something in your election manifesto we
can count the number of times you have
already changed that reality changes
when you change the law in the end a
majority of miracles governing coalition
voted against the opposition bill
anything else would have been a defeat
for the Chancellor